just before we get started i will say
that this video is sponsored by quincy
400.
if you ask the average american who john
hancock was you're most likely going to
get a bunch of vague answers something
about signing a name or an insurance
company or if they paid attention in
high school somebody involved with the
american revolution in short hardly
anybody nowadays knows who he is or what
he accomplished this is in stark
contrast from 250 years ago when
everyone in america knew john hancock he
was a hero to the cause of independence
from great britain one of the most
important members of the continental
congress and yes had a rather bold
signature which he put very prominently
on one of the most famous documents in
world history he was also filthy
stinking rich and always made sure
everyone knew it riding around town in
the grandest carriage anyone in boston
had ever seen dressed in the finest
clothes and accompanied by an entourage
that would make mark wahlberg jealous
his ostentatious displays of wealth only
made him more popular to the masses and
had circumstances been different he
might have been elected president of the
united states without john hancock the
course of the american revolution and
the country it helped found would have
been very different
john hancock iii was born on january 12
1737 in braintree massachusetts a
prosperous farming town 15 miles south
of boston both his father and
grandfather the first of two john
hancocks were church ministers in the
puritan tradition and as the eldest son
it is likely he would have followed in
their footsteps had his father not died
in 1744 when john was seven years old
young john's life took a dramatic turn
at this point in a plot twist worthy of
a dickens novel his uncle thomas hancock
arrived on the scene thomas had rejected
a ministerial career and gone into
business for himself founding the
trading company the house of hancock in
1724. his company shipped fish whale oil
and rum to london and brought back
manufactured goods that were sold in
stores in boston it was well known in
the city that if you wanted something
hancock was the man to visit and if he
didn't have it in stock he could get it
for you
for a price of course bowser pancake
quickly became one of the biggest
trading firms in america and thomas
hancock became fabulously rich perhaps
the wealthiest man in the colonies he
and his wife lydia lived in a huge manor
house on beacon hill in boston and their
lives were filled with everything they
could possibly need with one notable
exception they had been unable to
conceive a child thomas hancock wanted
an heir someone he could train up and
leave the business he had painstakingly
built from the ground up to after he
died thomas made a deal with his
brother's widow she would be provided
for and her children ensured of a good
education in exchange for allowing
thomas to adopt her eldest son and raise
him in boston as his own and so it was
that young john the humble preacher's
son was transported into a world of
luxury and commerce that he would reside
in for the rest of his life his aunt and
uncle doted on him and provided him with
the best education possible in
massachusetts culminating in a degree
from harvard college in 1754. his uncle
then started grooming him to become a
partner in the house of hancock teaching
him all the tricks of the trade of
transatlantic commerce including sending
him abroad to europe for a year to meet
thomas's business contacts during this
time the house of hancock prospered even
more thanks to the outbreak of war
between great britain and france the
conflict known as the seven years war in
europe and the french and indian war in
america saw the british emerge as the
undisputed masters of north america as
they captured all of french canada and
forced the french to see louisiana to
the spanish thomas hancock had secured
lucrative government contracts to
provide food and supplies to british
troops in america a dubai's nephew who
was coming into his own as a businessman
in 1764 thomas hancock died of a stroke
leaving most of his vast estate to 27
year old john who was now one of the
richest men in the colonies
the french and indian war came to an end
around the time that john hancock was
inheriting his fortune from his uncle
great britain had won the war and had
spent vast sums of money doing so
leaving the government 145 million
pounds in debt parliament was scrambling
for any new source of revenue that it
could find to refill their empty
treasury and soon they turned their eyes
to the american colonies which up to
that point had never been directly taxed
by the crown the trouble began in 1765
with the passage of the stamp act this
act required almost all documents from
birth certificates to playing cards to
be printed on special paper that carried
a revenue stamp the stamps were expected
to raise about 60 000 pounds a year less
than a shilling per day for each
colonist hardly an oppressive tax burden
but the colonists believed that the
increase in taxes represented an attempt
by great britain to exercise greater
control over the colonies and merchants
like hancock opposed it because they
feared the new tax would cut into their
profit margin and stifle trade an
alarming prospect in the midst of an
economic depression that had followed
the end of the war boston politician
samuel adams however successfully framed
the tax issue as a fundamental
constitutional argument that put america
on the road to independence adams and
his confederate who had eventually come
to be called the sons of liberty argued
that because the american colonies did
not send representatives to parliament
the parliament did not have the
authority to tax them only their locally
elected colonial legislatures did the
popular slogan no taxation without
representation was coined and became a
rallying cry for the sons of liberty one
would think that a wealthy merchant like
john hancock would have kept well away
from the stamp act controversy good
relations with another country were what
made him rich and considering that
britain banned direct trade between the
colonies and other foreign nations
keeping those good relations would be
essential in the success of his business
in the future so how then did hancock
emerge as one of the most prominent
opponents of the stamp act well he was
driven by two factors neither of them
particularly idealistic he didn't want
parliament to put their hands in his
pocket and take his money no matter how
much it actually ended up being and
perhaps more importantly he didn't want
a crown of hooligans to descend on his
mansion and burn it to the ground as it
happened to other merchants who
indicated their support for the act
hancock joined with adams as a leading
figure in the struggle against the stamp
act his prominence as one of boston's
leading merchants led credibility to the
rest of the group and his bankroll
provided much-needed financial support
to the cause hancock joined a
large-scale boycott of british goods in
protest of the act hoping that a
significant dip in trade revenues would
force parliament to repeal it it worked
after four months of devastating losses
on the part of british merchants who
suffered the most under the boycott
parliament repealed the stamp act they'd
not collected so much as a penny in
taxes from the colonies over it
parliament refused to concede defeat
having passed a declaratory act the day
after repealing the stamp act that
asserted their right to pass laws with
respect to the american colonies and
expect to have them enforced including
the right to tax the colonists in june
1767 they would try again to raise
revenue from the colonies by passing the
town's end acts a series of new import
duties on american goods as well as new
measures to deter smuggling in goods
without having to pay the tax the
colonies exploded in outrage at the
townsend axe and once again boston was
the center of resistance john hancock
who had parlayed his opposition to the
stamp act into election to boston's town
legislature quickly emerged as one of
boston's leading voices in the wake of
the towns and acts his wealth and
influence ensuring that when he spoke
people paid attention he straddled a
unique position in massachusetts society
being equally popular with the wealthy
merchant class who saw him as a
moderating force against the radical
elements within the patriot cause and
the middle and lower classes who knew
him as a philanthropist that really
seemed to care about their welfare he
would occupy this strange dual role for
the remainder of his life hancock became
a national figure in 1768 when british
customs officials seized one of his
trading ships the liberty after they
accused it of smuggling wine they were
supported by a british warship that
threatened to fire on the town if they
interfered this only incited the
bostonians further in parliament sent 1
200 british troops to occupy the town
attempting to restore order and enforce
the customs regulations hancock was
arrested and the royal governor
attempted to bankrupt him with a long
and expensive trial that ultimately went
nowhere as the charges were eventually
dropped for lack of evidence hancock had
lost a ship but it gained status
continent-wide as a martyr for the
patriot cause which he used to his full
advantage by 1770 the situation in
boston threatened to spill out of
control the british redcoats universally
hated by the colonists adopted a siege
mentality as they were constantly
harassed and attacked by mobs of angry
young men on the night of march the 5th
the fuse was finally lit when a group of
panic soldiers fired into a crowd
pelting them with rocks and ice trunks
killing vive colonists though all but
two of the soldiers would eventually be
acquitted in a subsequent trial the
boston massacre as it became known
provided the perfect propaganda fuel for
the sons of liberty led by samuel adams
to rouse the entire country into a
fuhrer over the heavy-handedness of
britain's dealings with the colonies
in the aftermath of the boston massacre
parliament repealed all but one of the
town's end acts a small import duty on
british tea the repeal had the effect of
cooling thought-tempers in boston and
elsewhere in the colonies and trade
resumed without further incidents it
seemed things were going back to normal
in america and hancock began to turn his
eye away from politics and back towards
his massive business interests as well
as beginning to court a lady that had
caught his eye miss dorothy dolly quincy
swaggering around town in his expensive
clothes and even more expensive carriage
hancock gave off the appearance of an
european nobleman though one that never
lost the common touch and had no trouble
retaining political office as his
popularity soared in the early 1770s
however in 1773 parliament misstepped
again passing the tea act which gave the
east india company exclusive rights to
sell tea in the american colonies
allowing them to sell tea far cheaper
than anyone else this would drive
hundreds of local merchants out of
business since tea was america's most
popular beverage and many depending on
importing it for their livelihoods for
many colonists this was the last straw
the tea act was almost universally seen
as an undemocratic measure that would
abridge free trade and potentially set
up other government monopolies in
america in december three ships loaded
with the east india tea docked in boston
and locals refused to allow the owner to
unload their cargo but the royal
governor threatened to sink the ships if
they returned to london with the tea
still on board so they were stuck on
december 16 an angry crowd marched the
docks in a small group of 50 men
disguised as mohawk indians went on
board the ships seized the chests of tea
and threw them into boston harbor over
300 chests were destroyed a value of
over a million dollars in today's money
in what became known as the boston tea
party parliament and the king were
furious they declared boston a city of
traitors and passed decrees that would
put the city under martial law closing
boston harbour to all trade and
stationing four regiments of redcoats in
the city to try and bring the rebellious
colonists to heal the crown also charged
john hancock and samuel adams with
treason and offered them to be brought
to england to face trial what had
started as a monetary dispute over taxes
was now marching towards war as
colonists spent 1774 stockpiling arms
and ammunition and organizing bands of
minutemen militia units that could be
called into action at a minute's notice
hancock was in the thick of it smuggling
arms into the countryside and paying for
more with his own funds as required on
april the 18th 1775 the british army
commanded by general thomas gage marched
out of boston their primary goal was to
seize the arms being stockpiled in the
town of concord 17 miles the west of
boston on the way they'd passed through
lexington where samuel adams and john
hancock were staying had they still been
there when the soldiers arrived it's
certain they would have been arrested
and hanged as traitors messengers made
runs throughout the night to warn the
countryside that the british were coming
the minutemen were called out and began
to assemble hancock wanted to be with
them but adams convinced him that his
skills were needed as a political leader
and not as a soldier the two of them
left lexington just in time as the sun
rose on april the 19th they heard shots
coming from the direction they had just
fled from signaling the start of the
revolutionary war
[Music]
adams and hancock left massachusetts and
headed to philadelphia where the second
continental congress was convening that
congress brought colonial leaders from
all across america together to decide on
what to do about great britain's actions
against them there was hardly universal
agreement on anything many of the more
moderate delegates especially those from
southern colonies accused new england of
dragging them all into war and favored
attempts at reconciliation with the
crown others wanted a total break with
britain to declare themselves an
independent country in order to moderate
between all the factions a universally
known figure was needed to be elected
president one respected by both north
and south patrician and plebian john
hancock was a hero by this point and he
fit the bill perfectly he was elected
unanimously what hancock would later
call the greatest honor of my life one
of congress's first tasks was to assume
control of the army of patriots that
were laid siege the british troops in
boston virginia planter george
washington was appointed
commander-in-chief of what was called
the continental army and dispatched to
boston to assume command washington was
the obvious choice not only because of
his military experience in the french
and indian war but because as a
southerner he would promote the fact
that this was an intercolonial effort
and not just a private war between new
england and the crown samuel adams who
by this point had essentially broken
with hancock over his moderate stance
would write that hancock craved the
command for himself though there is
little objective evidence to support
this hancock would support washington as
commanding general for the rest of the
war even when attempts were made by
others to replace him as president
hancock had to play referee between the
competing interests of different regions
colonies and individual delegates while
also supervising the construction of a
new continental government neither of
them were easy tasks even after king
george iii declared the american
colonies to be an open rebellion there
was still disagreement over whether
independence should be declared but the
continuous pressure of events would not
slow down further debate in march 1776
washington's army forced the british to
evacuate boston returning hancock's
beloved hometown to patriot control
meanwhile overtures were being made to
other european powers primarily
britain's chief rival france for aid to
the colonies but realistically they
couldn't expect help from outside unless
they made formal steps towards becoming
an independent nation in june while
congress continued to argue the question
of independence hancock formed a
committee of five delegates headed by
thomas jefferson to draft a declaration
of independence from great britain the
thought was once congress finally
settled the question a formal document
was going to be needed anyway so they
might as well get started working on it
now on june 28th the committee submitted
a draft mostly written by jefferson of a
document that would eventually become
one of the most influential in world
history on july the 4th the declaration
was adopted by congress and at the end
of that day's session hancock's attitude
his desk and was the first delegate to
sign it his signature had always been
bold but the one he scrawled on the
declaration of independence is
particularly impressive done in the
fluent calligraphy he learned at harvard
it was far larger and more legible than
the signatures of the other delegates
and would probably become the most
famous signature in american history
it's so well known that even today
putting your john hancock on something
is a slang term for signing your name
in october 1777 hancock left the
position as president of congress now
temporarily relocated to york
pennsylvania because the british had
occupied philadelphia he had spent more
than two years shaping the destiny of
this new nation and needed a break he
also wanted to put his personal stamp on
the future politics of his home state as
massachusetts worked to establish their
new post-colonial state government he
took up the mantle of commanding general
of the massachusetts state militia and
led his troops in an assault on the
british held port of newport rhode
island his efforts at soldiery were
rather less successful than his
endeavors in congress however as the
expedition proved a disaster and almost
cost the americans their hard on
alliance with the french hancock was
able to repair the damage through
skilled diplomacy and the french would
go on to provide a crucial role in the
final defeat of the british at yorktown
in 1781. the victory would ensure
american independence as it was a
stipulation for the treaty of paris that
ended the war in 1783. hancock meanwhile
celebrated from his opulent mansion on
beacon hill having been elected the
first governor of the commonwealth of
massachusetts in 1780. he was in charge
of a state that was in the grips of an
increasingly desperate economic crisis
having gone into huge amounts of debt to
pay for the costs of the war and printed
currency being virtually worthless
hancock managed the issue as best he
could while also increasingly suffering
from gout a debilitating condition that
causes painful swelling of the joints
finally in january 1785 he'd had enough
resigning his post and apparently
retiring from the political scene you
would think that the ailing man had
earned it after 20 years of political
activity especially since winning
america's independence had cost him his
business the house of hancock had never
really recovered from the effects of the
war and a good part of his fortune but
events would conspire against his
retirement as western massachusetts
farmers erupted in rebellion fed up with
high taxes and land seizures by state
officials hancock's successor james
baudoin faced the brunt of the criticism
for his mismanagement of both the
state's finances and the crisis itself
and in 1787 he was soundly defeated at
the polls and replaced with a reluctant
john hancock hancock returned to the
governorship a much diminished man his
nine-year son had died in january after
a four-while ice skating leaving him and
his wife dolly childless his gout also
flared up with increasing regularity
despite this he managed the state as
best he could including ensuring that
massachusetts ratified the new united
states constitution in february of 1788
had he been in better health there was
even some talk about nominating him for
president of the united states and the
expectation that he would serve as
george washington's vice president but
it wasn't meant to be as by this point
hancock could barely walk in his last
years he increasingly became a governor
and name only with his illness
preventing him from exercising most of
the duties of the office he was
substituted by the lieutenant governor
samuel adams who had made peace with
hancock after 15 years of enmity between
them
on october 8 1793 john hancock died at
home age 57. the death of the governor
touched off a wave of mournings
throughout the state especially in
boston where he received a lavish state
funeral a week later he was one of the
most popular men in america when he died
yet now over 200 years later hardly
anyone remembers his name or
accomplishments in any great detail his
gravesite at the old granary burying
ground in boston lacked a monument atop
it for over a hundred years until it was
finally dedicated in 1896. hancock had a
large insurance company headquartered in
boston and a world war ii era aircraft
carrier named after him but otherwise
it's as though he was totally forgotten
one has to ask
why one reason might be hancock's own
fault unlike some of the more prolific
writers of his day like hamilton or the
adams cousins hancock left few personal
papers and writings for historians to
study while he could certainly write
well and his oratory was inspiring he
wasn't a pamphleteer he didn't submit
essays to newspapers or published books
he was a man of action more so than a
man of letters that makes it difficult
to talk about him centuries later the
other reason is probably more complex in
the years after the revolutionary
generation died off the following
generations began to build a cult of
personality around the early presidents
of the united states especially
washington and jefferson so that anyone
who wasn't elected president would
likely be left behind relegated to the
collective term founding father even
today this persists as many american
school children are taught the names of
all the presidents leaving little room
for non-presidents if they are
remembered at all it's as part of an
anecdote like benjamin franklin's flying
a kite in a lightning storm or john
hancock's grandiose signature on the
declaration of independence which is a
real shame because as you hopefully saw
today john hancock was an important and
interesting figure in early america
worthy of recognition it's difficult to
encompass all that he was in a short
video like this so we hope you'll take
the opportunity to explore further into
his life and the legend of this man so
that he doesn't remain just a forgotten
founding father